[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica 7 días este es un magacín
informativo 100% dedicado al continente
africano aquí vamos la mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
en senegal la homosexualidad sigue
siendo considerada un delito programarla
wachovia expande cada día
personas de la comunidad lgbt y sufren
actos de violencia y recientemente se
convocó una manifestación pidiendo
castigos más severos para quienes tengan
relaciones con personas de su mismo sexo
el país más joven del mundo se perfila
como una nueva potencia en el mundo del
baloncesto los deportistas de sudán del
sur no sólo se destacan por su estatura
sino por su talento y varios de ellos ya
están en las principales ligas del
planeta y las 60 mos en este capítulo
áfrica siete días la más reciente
canción del rapero español
ecuatoguineano hecho jim titulada
carasucia un nuevo videoclip
autobiográfico que relata las
experiencias del cantante durante su
infancia en una sociedad racista
iniciamos entonces con la información in
africa siete días y empezamos en senegal
donde la homofobia persiste
recientemente varias personas de la
comunidad lgtb tumbas han sido linchadas
y los ataques han quedado registrados en
vídeos publicados también en las redes
sociales incluso en mayo pasado se
organizó en dakar una manifestación para
exigir que la homosexualidad sea
reprimida con más severidad
es un testimonio poco común samba tiene
27 años y es gay y ese no es su nombre
real pues tratamos de proteger su
identidad en las últimas semanas el
joven está aún más prevenido de lo
habitual o
conversos
vivimos como los criminales que estamos
buscando nos tratan peor que animales
cuando los jóvenes homofóbicos de 20
golpean y hasta te matan por eso ahora
tenemos miedo
por pulmón donde vivían sospechaban que
soy gay por eso no pude seguir viviendo
allí
recientemente el clima se ha tornado más
tenso en torno a la homosexualidad
debido al rechazo masivo contra esta
comunidad en senegal a finales de mayo
un colectivo de asociaciones
conservadoras se manifestó en dakar para
exigir la criminalización de la
homosexualidad con penas de hasta 10
años de prisión según muchos testimonios
los ataques se han multiplicado desde
entonces
y la constitución de senegal protege el
derecho a la vida protege el derecho a
la integridad física de las personas y
esta constitución no discrimina entre
ciudadanos en relación a la protección
otorgada por lo que el estado debería
garantizar que estos actos de violencia
no se repitan
en cualquier caso los perpetradores son
arrestados y llevados ante la justicia
el código penal senegalés se prevé
actualmente hasta cinco años de prisión
por delitos tipificados como actos
contra la naturaleza y la
despenalización no está en la agenda de
los congresistas
cultural en senegal tenemos nuestros
valores culturales nuestros valores
sociales nuestras creencias culturales
es sobre esta base que construimos las
leyes que todos estamos obligados a
respetar y estas leyes rechazan
cualquier forma de actos contra la
naturaleza
pacto contranatura más de la mitad de
los países del áfrica subsahariana
reprimen la homosexualidad algunos
incluso con la pena de muerte
sudan del sur es el país más joven del
mundo pero ya tiene un lugar en la
escena internacional del baloncesto el
equipo nacional entró recientemente en
el top 100 de la operación internacional
de baloncesto fiba varios grandes
jugadores sursudaneses han llegado a la
nba en los eeuu es una de las únicas
canchas de baloncesto en ciudad del sur
antes de su apertura en 2015 los
jugadores entrenaron aquí en un campo de
concreto simple la fundación world en lo
ha convertido en un lugar de
entrenamiento para jóvenes talentos de
caer a busquets
queremos educar a nuestros hijos
enseñarles habilidades para la vida
habilidades de baloncesto les damos
oportunidades para continuar su
educación estamos muy orgullosos del
baloncesto emergente en nuestro país
cuando vamos a competir fuera
representamos a sudan del sur
más in tiene sólo 16 años con sus dos
metros de estatura sueña con ser
seleccionado para ingresar al equipo del
año que viene y tal vez algún día jugar
en el extranjero
mi sueño salir a la calle cuando vengo
aquí después de ayudar a los niños que
no pueden jugar baloncesto para que les
proporcionen cosas buenas ese es mi
sueño ser un profesional y ayudar en la
casa sudan del sur no se trata solo de
guerra sudan del sur está avanzando y
está haciendo grandes cosas
en yubá el baloncesto también está en el
corazón de muchos espectáculos
a principios de este año en la selección
nacional participó en la eliminatoria de
afrobasket en ruanda donde tuvo una
actuación excepcional
sólo para este periodista deportivo el
baloncesto del ciudad del sur todavía
carece de recursos we have the talent
bot y el outs y tenemos los talentos
dentro y por nada este país todo lo que
se necesita ahora es para los
responsables pues la federación el
propio gobierno federation
melitza of
sports porque un deporte no se
desarrollará si el gobierno no viene a
dar una mano
a pesar de todo en tan sólo 10 años
sudán del sur ha subido al puesto 97 en
la clasificación de la federación
internacional de baloncesto
hablamos ahora de kenia porque el
dibujante gado se ha convertido en una
figura nacional durante casi 30 años sus
dibujos se han publicado en periódicos
de todo el mundo y ha ganado numerosos
premios alrededor del planeta
este es el ritual diario de gottfried
mantengo a compra los principales
periódicos de kenia en los cuales es
conocido por su arte cada ves el
dibujante más temido por los jefes de
estado de áfrica oriental
debe ser un animal político no solo debe
saber lo que está pasando en kenia
sino también en el resto de la región y
en el mundo
el caricaturista dibuja tanto los
contratiempos de los políticos locales
como las noticias internacionales así lo
hizo en esta edición del periódico para
el que trabaja de estándar
esto representa la juramentación de
museveni
este otro dibujo evoca la distribución
de vacunas contra el kobe que avanza
lentamente en áfrica también critica a
los bombardeos israelíes sobre gaza
dibujante no se abstiene de ningún tema
af cat branch de slim tengo carta blanca
obviamente hay temas difíciles y
delicados de tratar por ejemplo los
temas religiosos siempre son muy
delicados
pero debemos encontrar una solución para
lograr hablar de temas difíciles los
caricaturistas de prensa tienen esa
misión y debemos llevarla a cabo
todas las estatuas son protect en 2016
esta libertad le costó un trabajo pero
pronto encontró un nuevo empleador y
sigue analizando las noticias la prensa
es relativamente libre en kenia en
comparación con el resto de la región en
esta oportunidad se burla de un
sindicalista cuyo nombre acaba de
asignar se le a una calle
tiene muchos problemas de drenaje y
muchas otras cosas
así que sólo estoy sugiriendo que
construyamos una tubería de
alcantarillado y la llamemos así
en 2022 kenia elegirá a su nuevo
presidente y los políticos locales ya
están advertidos
era una de las voces que lidere la
opinión pública también en costa de
márfil un semanario creado hace 22 años
no dudó en utilizar caricaturas para
ampliar los límites de la libertad de
expresión su fundador supo conducir este
periódico a través de las diferentes
crisis que han marcado la historia de
este país
todo lo que la sand zohore necesita para
contarnos una historia es una hoja y
algunos trazos de rotulador de hecho es
back booking se está impacientando
estamos apenas a ocho y él quiere que el
calendario corre rápido para que llegue
el 17 para este redactor jefe esta
disciplina cotidiana se ha ido
convirtiendo poco a poco en una
necesidad real
cuando no estoy dibujando me siento
frustrado yo juré que ha hecho
caricaturas durante más de 30 años creo
hace 22 su propio periódico llamado bis
que se ha convertido en una referencia
en costa de márfil la historia de vis es
la de una larga conquista por la
libertad de expresión y la independencia
inicialmente cuando pensamos beach la
imprenta del periódico del gobierno nos
imprimía así que contábamos con muy
pocos ejemplares a pesar del sentido de
burla de los marfileños y su clase
política la caricatura no siempre está
exenta de peligro durante el golpe
militar de 2003 logró evitar que el
ejército acabara con su periódico
se suponía que tenía que ir a la
redacción ese día la gente me dijo que
no debía moverme los soldados estaban en
el barrio
creado más de dos décadas bis ha
cubierto varios periodos de crisis en el
país para zohore el papel del dibujante
es despertar conciencias pero no echarle
leña al fuego
cuando el país está realmente dividido y
sentimos cierta tensión en la población
tratamos de ser conciliadores pero
cuando nos damos cuenta de que todo está
un poco más tranquilo lo pasamos muy
bien giramos a la izquierda o giramos a
la derecha escribimos lo que queremos
creo que uno puede convertirse en una
paloma de paz o puede convertirse en un
crítico realmente somos mitad ángeles
mitad demonios
ángeles o demonios una cosa es segura la
impertinencia de zohore y su equipo no
se desvanecerá con los años y
finalizamos con música porque hablamos
con el rapero ecuatoguineano y español
elio gene una de las más importantes
figuras del hip hop en español desde
madrid nos habló del videoclip de su
canción y cara sucia donde relata las
experiencias de su infancia en relación
con el racismo
muy buenas familias soy el sol y estoy
aquí para hablar o se emite una cara
sucia cara sucia no es uno de mis temas
más populares pero sí que es uno de los
temas más importantes de los que he
escrito por varios motivos el primer
motivo sería porque es autobiográfico en
cuenta la historia de un niño ya que
desde pequeño está señalado por una
mayoría social de piel clara como
alguien diferente a peor
cuando haces un tema autobiográfico y te
siente representado por él pues
evidentemente te toca de ahí que sea
importante para mí el segundo motivo por
el que es importante es porque creo que
se necesita que los más jóvenes que
puedan llegar a sentir algo similar a lo
que sencillo entiendan que no están en
absoluto solos que somos muchos y son
muchas los que hemos pasado por por
situaciones similares el sentimiento de
comunidad es importante y el tercer
motivo por el que creo que es relevante
este tema es porque se nos ha enseñado
desde siempre que hay un tipo de persona
estándar que es aquella que tiene el
pelo liso que tiene los labios finos y
tiene
la pila piel clara buenos momentos de
reprende repensarnos eso no eres
estándar por ser blanco la estándar y
that tiene que ver con todos y cada uno
de nosotros y de nosotros espero que
disfruten del tema
más tarde
[Música]
justamente con la buena música de chol
jin y su canción cara sucia finalizamos
este capítulo de áfrica siete días pero
los invitamos a continuar con más en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom nos
vemos más adelante con más información
estos france
el rechazo de la gente inculta levanta
esa preciosa en que la lluvia
aprende que eres diferente no
de niños se fuerte
al rechazo de la gente inculta y hasta
esa preciosa que era sucia entre peleas
en el cole niño se hacía adolescente se
ganó un respeto entre sus compañeros
pero conocer a alguien es sin tratar de
nuevo tiene que demostrar que es uno más
constantemente chicos llega a creer que
todo ha pasado es el líder de su grupo
es el más fuerte es el más rápido pero
chico conoce a chica un día y vuelven
las dudas chico y chica ha rehusado lo
que oyes no soy racista pero
[Música]